women ruin everything really we've
ruined the workforce with me too we even
ruined women's sport by whining and
complaining about her pay now we're
ruining gyms yes ruining gyms there was
a woman that decided to make a skit of
how women are just ruining the gym P up
hi guys this is a tutorial on how to
make a guy look like a creep at the gym
first I like to set up the barbell in
the free weight area directly in front
of my Victim wearing tiny shorts then I
start doing RDL for him to see that
fat and grab his attention then
stop my workout turn around and confront
him about perving on me making sure I'm
getting all of this on camera next I'll
green screen my video and talk about how
I feel violated and then post on my
social media so I receive comments from
other girls saying go sis see you next
time